antennes de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir et bienvenue sur
le plateau du journal à la une ce soir
le cri d'alarmé du premier ministre à
quelques jours seulement du grand retour
sur la route des vacances
michel rocard s'en prend ouvertement au
chauffard leur inconscience coûtent
chaque année près de 100 milliards de
francs à la collectivité dans quelques
instants nous vous donneront un aperçu
des mesures qui doivent être prises en
conseil des ministres dans les jours qui
viennent
en attendant voici les autres grands ti
le journal de 20h
en pologne l'épreuve de force est
engagée entre solidarité le général
j'arrivais les skis dès ce soir le
couvre-feu interviendra dans les zones
sensibles à moscou le mouvement de grève
est qualifiée d'illégale nouvelle
flambée de violence en irlande du nord
un soldat britannique a trouvé la mort
hier soir à belfast le gouvernement de
madame thatcher part est actuellement
réduit à l'impuissance face à l'ira
confirmation du dégel des relations
entre la france et l'iran c'est officiel
la france va lever partiellement
l'embargo sur les produits pétroliers
iraniens cinéma l'un des événements de
la rentrée se déroule demain sandrine
bonnaire et daniel auteuil se partagent
la vedette du dernier film de claude
sautet son titre quelques jours avec moi
j'en ai assez de ces destins fauché sur
le bord de la route ou encore la france
et d'une inconscience suicidaire c'est
michel rocard qui parle ainsi à nos
confrères de france soir
le premier ministre rappelle notamment
que chaque année les accidents de la
route coûtent en moyenne 100 milliards
de francs à la collectivité français 100
milliards de francs un chiffre colossal
qui représente près de 8 % du budget
national pour faire face au fléau
le gouvernement annoncera prochainement
une nouvelle série de mesures une
communication du ministre des transports
a d'ailleurs été inscrite à l'ordre du
jour du conseil des ministres de demain
dominique verdeilhan en 87 la route a
tué 9855 personne fait 57 milles 102
blessés graves et 179 1736 blessés
légers la france reste l'un des mauvais
élèves de l'europe en matière de
sécurité routière avec 467 morts sur la
route pour un million de véhicules en
circulation
loin devant la grande bretagne qui
totalise seulement 2 166 morts
drame humain mais aussi hémorragie
financière
les accidents de la route représentent
une dépense de 1500 francs par français
soit en moyenne 4000 50 francs par
ménage
l'équivalent d'un mois de smic coût pour
la collectivité 84 milliards de francs
une somme qui se décompose mans 54
milliards de francs de dédommagement des
victimes et 30 milliards de francs
en réparation des dégâts matériels et
les accidents engendrent des coûts
indirects journées de travail perdues
pension ou handicapées des coups
difficiles à chiffrer un bilan financier
qui ne risque pas de s'améliorer on a
constaté depuis janvier dernier une
augmentation de 11 % des accidents et de
16 % des tués devant ce que michel
rocard rappelle l'inconscience
suicidaire des français les pouvoirs
publics pourraient prendre de nouvelles
mesures de prévention parmi celles les
plus souvent cités le contrôle technique
des véhicules un contrôle en vigueur
actuellement pour tout véhicule de plus
de cinq ans que l'automobiliste souhaite
revendre
un contrôle qui s'appliquerait désormais
tous les deux ou trois ans à tout
véhicule avec obligation au propriétaire
d'effectuer les réparations
le permis de conduire à points
déjà en application dans de nombreux
pays européens
l'automobiliste dispose à l'issue de son
permis d'un quota de points des points
qui lui sont retirés à chaque infraction
une perte massive de ce crédit pouvant
provoquer la suspension du permis
une mesure qui ne concerne pas ceux qui
sont déjà détenteurs du permis de
conduire coup dur pour les
automobilistes adeptes du diesel ils
sont près de 20% et oui 20 % dans
l'hexagone nos confrères de la tribune
l'expansion l'annoncé dès ce matin à la
une du journal
le gouvernement va donner un coup
d'arrêt au diesel par la fiscalité
pourquoi et bien tout simplement
semble-t-il pour harmoniser les prix
avec nos partenaires européens
concrètement on a appris cet après midi
que le ministre de l'industrie proposé
d'augmenter le prix sur le gasoil de
près de 4 centimes
explications de jean pierre métivet
depuis plusieurs années le diesel n'est
plus réservé à quelques professionnels
comme ces taxis ou les routiers
le marché a même littéralement explosé
plus d'une voiture sur cinq vendus cette
année qu'une diesel et en dix ans la
consommation de gazole augmenté
dix fois plus vite que celles de
l'essence le phénomène devrait même
s'amplifier avec l'arrivée du pot
catalytique qui renchérit le prix des
voitures roulant au super une bonne
affaire pour l'automobiliste mais pas
pour l'état les taxes sur le gazole
rapporte deux fois moins que celle du
super augmenter cet axe c'est donc la
meilleure dissuasion vu la différence du
prix d'achat de la mouture avec une
bonne tenue récente d'un diesel alors
que plus l'utilité d'achat
cher d'hachette d'un diesel c'est parce
que c'est économique deux autres
arguments sont avancés par le
gouvernement
la france est et qui s'y terre pour le
raffinage du gazole et une prochaine
directive de bruxelles va demander à la
france de réduire l'écart entre le
gazole et le super pour commencer roger
fauroux propose une hausse de 4 centimes
plus prudents face aux réactions
possibles
le ministère de l'économie a dit lui
qu'il étudie le dossier en pologne le
général jari celle ci a finalement
choisi l'épreuve de force dès ce soir à
23h le couvre-feu entrera en vigueur
dans trois régions polonaises
particulièrement touché par les grèves
quant aux unités anti émeutes
elles demeurent déployés devant les
usines occupées ce soir tous les
observateurs sont d'accord pour dire que
ce conflit est assurément le plus grave
qu'ait connue la pologne depuis la
proclamation de l'état de siège
c'était souvenez-vous en 1981 le point
avec martine laroche-joubert la de
liberté solidarité accrue martelé
aujourd'hui encore en pologne est de
plus en plus fort malgré les dernières
menaces du pouvoir dominant chantier du
sinn fein aciéries un crime qu'il unit
crû de 70 grévistes l'espoir au coeur
même les plus anonymes
j'ai l'impression que nous allons nous
battre et ça c'est pour notre bien
commun une volonté de lutter jusqu'au
bout qui semble-t-il dépasse lech walesa
lui-même il met en garde aujourd'hui le
pouvoir contre tout recours à la force
mais se déclare prêt à dit alain madgin
devons dialoguer un mot qu par est
ignoré le général ministre de
l'intérieur qui hier soir à la
télévision en grand uniforme sous
l'emblème de l'aigle polonais n'avaient
comme menace à la bouche tribunaux
d'exception prison et couvre-feu
ce soir en effet pour la première fois
depuis l'instauration de l'état de
guerre en 1981
le couvre-feu a été décrété à yatreb y
ait au sud de la pologne
la zone la plus dure les communications
téléphoniques avec les entreprises en
grève sont pipés les journalistes et
carpes et aucun accord
semble en vue pour le moment et pour la
première fois hier soir la télévision
soviétique a diffusé des images des
grèves en pologne nos confrères vous
allez les entendre ont surtout insisté
sur le côté illégale du mouvement de
grève pour le reste le silence est de
rigueur c'est la langue de bois pas d'
analyse peu de commentaires
rien ne laisse à penser qu'une faillite
prochaine du général george szell ce qui
aurait des répercussions sur la
pérestroïka chers amis ras el ghorba de
chauffe
l'analyse de jacques merlino bigras et
mihail cette chanson est pour toi de
nous de nouvelles réformes ira il voilà
ce que l'on chantait à varsovie il y à
tout juste six semaines
rire chansons applaudissements la visite
de mikhaïl gorbatchev en pologne voulait
alors offrir l'image la détente et
surtout montré que l'homme de la
pérestroïka tenait apparaître
publiquement aux côtés de son ami
j'arrose skis à ce geste succède
aujourd'hui un grand embarras des grèves
dans un pays socialiste l'armée
mobilisée un ministre en uniforme un
télévision des arrestations
tout cela risque fort d cornet ou même
d'abîmer l'image libéral numéro un
soviétique et celui ci se trouvent
piégés
s'il pousse au dialogue il donne un bon
point solidarité s'il encourage la
répression il montre les limites de sa
politique
alors en attendant que moscou se sort de
ce guêpier les vieux réflexes reviennent
et la télévision elle-même retrouve les
accents de la langue de bois
à preuve cet extrait du journal télévisé
d'hier ne pousse pas abouti à ce titre
ds un ton auquel on était plus habitué
et qui confirme bien que les crises
polonaise risque de brouiller la
transparence tant souhaité par
gorbatchev
c'est officiel la france va lever
progressivement l'embargo sur les
produits pétroliers y règne un embargo
qui avait été décidée souvenez-vous dans
le climat de fièvre de l'affairé gordji
mais qui n'avait plus vraiment
de raison d'être dans la mesure où la
plupart des dossiers brûlants entre la
france et l'iran ont été réglés ou en
passe de l'être
information importante qui confirme en
tout cas le dégel des relations entre
les deux pays
bernard benyamin c'était il ya un an
presque jour pour jour en pleine affaire
gordji le gouvernement français décide
et l'embargo sur le pétrole iranien
depuis paris et téhéran ont entrepris la
normalisation de leurs rapports
mais surtout l'iran et l'irak viennent
d'accepter de mettre fin sous l'égide
des nations unies à une guerre
meurtrière
de plus de 8 ans concrètement cela va
donc se traduire par une série d'accords
de troc en échange du pétrole la france
fournira à l'iran des produits
alimentaires en particulier de la viande
qui manque cruellement à ce pays exemple
après sa guerre entre l'irak
il a été signé pour 30 mille tonnes de
viande à prix fixe déjà fixé et 30000
tonnes de viande dont le prix sera fixé
ultérieurement si les miens ça fait en
tout soixante mille tonnes de viande et
ça portera sur 800 millions de francs
environ de chiffre d'affaires donc je
crois que la france étant par tradition
un pays exportateur de produits
agroalimentaires montrera la france avec
des céréales avec la volaille notamment
par exemple et peut-être d'autres
produits et en la matière la france un
retard considérable à rattraper au début
du conflit du golfe le volume de nos
exportations vers téhéran a gagné 3
milliards de francs
ils n'étaient plus que 2 680 millions de
francs en 1986 nouvelle flambée de
violence en irlande du nord trois jours
après l'attentât qui a coûté la vie à
huit soldats anglais l'ira a revendiqué
hier soir un nouvel attentat contre un
militaire britannique à belfast
la victime est un officier de la royal
navy depuis le début de l'année soixante
deux personnes ont trouvé la mort en
ulster et de plus en plus des voix
s'élèvent pour dénoncer l'impuissance du
gouvernement de margaret thatcher face à
l'armée républicaine irlandaise pas la
face à lire hier la dame de fer a durci
le ton face aux terroristes
mais elle a dit non une nouvelle fois à
la procédure d'internement une procédure
qui permettrait aux forces de l'ordre de
tannique d'appréhender certains suspects
à londres le commentaire de philippe
harrouard à londres on est persuadé que
l'ira a lancé sa campagne la plus
violente contre les forces britanniques
en ulster le meurtrière soir à belfast
d'un officier de la navy trois jours
après la taxe d'un autocar transportant
des soldats le confirme en cinq mois
22 militaires ont été tués pour les
spécialistes cela va continuer l'ira
applique la tactique du viet congs pour
prouver qu'une petite organisation est
capable de chasser la puissante armée
britannique d'irlande du nord
car c'est bien là le but l'ira bénéficie
d'un armement puissant et sophistiqué
venant de libye comparable à celui saisi
sur les secondes en novembre dernier
mais d'autres chargements sont arrivés à
destination pour enrayer cette violence
mark thatcher a une marge de manoeuvre
étroite
faut-il céder aux voix les plus extrêmes
comme celles du pasteur paix ce lait qui
réclament le retour aux lois d'exception
avec emprisonnement des suspects sans
procès c'est peu probable
bien que madame thatcher n'écarter
aucune option les lois d'exception c'est
mauvais pour l'image de la
grande-bretagne est bon pour la
propagande de l'ira on se dirige plutôt
vers une offensive tous azimuts contre
l'organisation terroriste irlandaise il
s'agit avec l'aide des services secrets
d'essayer de décapiter lira de bloquer
ces fonds qui proviennent surtout de
raquette
il faut aussi renforcer la coopération
avec la république d'irlande pour mieux
démasquer les terroristes enfin il
faudra sans doute accroître la présence
militaire en irlande du nord qui est
pour l'instant de 10000 à efficacité
égale discrétion disait encore madame
thatcher confronté un défi terroristes
sans précédent depuis bientôt dix ans
qu'elle est au pouvoir
alors après l'interrogation à londres la
réalité sur le terrain
depuis 48 heures grâce à nos envoyés
spéciaux vous avez découvert tour à tour
l'armée britannique et la communauté
protestante ce soir jean martineau et
philipp etter ont enquêté au sein de la
communauté catholique en irlande du nord
les catholiques sont trois fois moins
nombreux que les protestants ils font
surtout figure de parent pauvre tant au
niveau de l'emploi de la justice ou
encore de la police
depuis longtemps les catholiques veulent
être intégré à la république d'irlande
mais ils sont divisés sur les moyens qui
pourraient leur permettre de mettre fin
à la présence britannique
regardez les murs qui proclame partout
la légitimité de la lutte armée
des gamins de misère et de chômage qui
trimballe déjà des regard d'adulte des
gamins qui se parent chaque fois des
couleurs de l'irlande
chaque fois qu ici défilent contre la
présence britannique en irlande du nord
mais chez les catholiques pauvres de
belfast ouest
on ne dit pas présence mais occupations
chez eux la guerre d'indépendance a
repris en 69 pour un frère un ami tuées
blessées ou emprisonnées par les forces
de sécurité je suis électricien de
métier une profession très honorable à
je ne portent pas d'uniforme mais je
déteste la présence ici des britanniques
et de leurs institutions
j résistera toujours toujours et encore
mon identité et irlandaise est
catholique et cela ne va pas changer
armée républicaine irlandaise l'ira
si l'ennemi mortel de l'armée
britannique est ici chez lui c'est
justement affaire d'identité irlandaise
les hommes de l'ira qui frappe dans
l'ombre se veulent les successeurs des
héros de l'indépendance de l'irlande
ils sont traqués par les britanniques
paradoxe leurs sympathisants ont leur
parti politique et peuvent légalement
défilé à belfast ouest unanimes pour
réclamer le départ des britanniques et
la réunification l'irlande les
catholiques d'irlande du nord ne
défilent pas toujours ensemble une
grande moitié d'entre eux refusent la
stratégie de l'iera et condamne ces
violences tout autant que celle des
extrémistes protestants presque un autre
monde à 50 km à l'ouest de belfast dans
la petite ville catholique de deng et
veut de nouveau un défilé mais ici une
communauté presque prospère certes on
vote pour l'irlande irlandaise encore et
toujours mais pas celle de l'ira et de
la lutte armée comme les autres le vieux
mac cormick désavoue les assassinats de
soldats britanniques
avant d'ajouter si les britanniques ne
semblait pas nous finirions certainement
par trouver une solution entre irlandais
les autres au télégramme d'actualité
commenté par michel mompontet ensuite
nous vous expliquerons pourquoi certains
touristes bout de la côte d'azur depuis
quelques temps mais oui
au moins 25 blessés dont la plupart
sérieusement c'est le bilan provisoire
de l'attentât perpétré cet après midi à
east london en afrique du sud
c'est dans un fast-food que la bombe
était déposé une vingtaine de personnes
ont péri cette année en afrique du sud
dans des attentats similaires attentats
systématiquement attribuée par le
pouvoir blanc à l'insee le mouvement
anti apartheid
les affrontements sporadiques ont repris
ce matin dans la bande de gaza bravant
les consignes du couvre-feu des
palestiniens ils ont manifesté l'un
d'entre eux a été blessé par des tirs
un autre est décédé hier soir le couvre
feu israélien continue sur gaza c'est
cet homme jacques fourni qui sera demain
après le conseil des ministres le
nouveau pdg de la sncf
ancien pdg de gaz de france cet énarque
de 59 ans remplacera monsieur philippe
rouby doigts qui avait démissionné le 7
août dernier à la suite des accidents
ferroviaires de l'été hold up manqué
mais hold up sanglant ce matin dans une
bijouterie de perpignan un policier tué
et cinq blessés dans les deux banques
servent eux ce soir sous les verrous il
s'agissait de deux récidiviste déjà
condamné pour vol qualifié à 10 ans
qu'ils étaient libérables seulement en
1990 peut-être la fin de l'âge d'or du
tourisme sur la côte d'azur rassurez
vous c'est toujours là bas un sous le
soleil que l'on enregistre le plus grand
nombre de coups de soleil au centimètre
carré
il n'en demeure pas moins que les
français comme certains étrangers
d'ailleurs commencé à bouder les rivages
de la grande bleue l'explication est
toute simple
les vacanciers ne se contentent plus
d'une place au soleil bref 188
on ne veut plus beau est idiot pour
reprendre le slogan reportage à la new
wave ski
1912 l'inauguration du negresco est un
triomphe cette année là cela fait 50 ans
déjà que la côte d'azur a pris son envol
l'ascension s'est poursuivie longtemps
mais depuis ses toutes dernières années
s'il n'ya pas crise il y as
essoufflement 8 millions de touristes
fréquentent chaque année la côte d'azur
la moitié sont des étrangers en majorité
des jeunes au pouvoir d'achat faible les
riches étrangers sont moins présents qu
autrefois les familles royales se font
rares remplacé par la grande bourgeoisie
arabe du golfe environ 20000 personnes
et par les américains moins dépensiers
mais plus nombreux 500 mille par an la
clientèle française
elle a ralenti ses départs vers la côte
d'azur évidemment tout est relatif ce
que l'estivant gagne en confort ce sont
les commerçants qui distille le perdent
en chiffre d'affaires ya une régression
des clientèles plus en plus je ne sais
pas
moi je suis là depuis
49 j'ai fait vingt ans de plage sans et
puis sa descente ou alors la côte d'azur
se serait-elle endormi sur ses lauriers
la tendance est aujourd'hui aux vacances
actives même si les récalcitrants sont
encore nombreux la clientèle à qui l'on
propose des séjours bon marché à
l'étranger ne se satisfait plus de deux
mètres carrés pour bronzer
donc il faut faire évoluer très vite la
côte d'azur grand pour sens bien sur ta
patience quand elle la considère
toujours comme une destination
parfaitement à la mode est parfaitement
adapté à 6 ans concrètement ça donne
quoi concrètement ça veut dire vous
l'avez constaté vous même que les
clients sont de moins intéressés de
moyens aux intéressés par le seul fait
de rester sur la plage à bronzer
en fait c'est la notion de club qui
revient le plus large au dessus et
personne n'est attendue mais il faut
proposer de plus en plus sa clientèle
des forfaits tout compris
ainsi on tente de multiplier les
enclaves de loisirs dans des surfaces
limitées mandelieu la napoule par
exemple propose une carte de réduction
pour une dizaine de clubs de sport
les gens sont de plus en plus à la
demande d'activités d'activités
sportives d'activités de loisirs et de
détente pendant leur séjour de vacances
et c'est l'époque on essaye de le suivre
justement avec la carte multi sports oui
mais les plages méditerranéennes sont
souvent très petit
l'évolution nécessaire souhaité de la
côte d'azur vers les animations les
activités risque d'être bien difficile
en haute saison
le long du littoral
le sport carton rouge pour eric cantona
48 heures après ses déclarations
fracassantes ce terme n'est pas trop
fort des déclarations qui mettait
directement en cause le sélect le
sélectionneur national notre nouvelle
star du football est suspendu de toute
sélection nationale jusqu'à nouvel ordre
justification de la décision par jacques
fournet fayard le président de la
fédération française de football la
première c'est de renvoyer en ce qui
concerne le joueur et la suspension
éventuelle renvoyé au niveau des
commissions compétentes
nous n'avons en effet pas de possibilité
de pouvoir disciplinaire direct il est
absolument indispensable qu'il y ait
pour le fautif ou celui qui est entendu
de pouvoir faire un appel auprès d'une
instance supérieure donc le bureau ne
pouvait pas assurer cette mission et
permettent un appel donc nous renvoyons
sur ce plan-là la commission compétente
la deuxième chose en ce qui concerne les
sélections nationales nous avons pris la
décision d'exclure eric cantona jusqu'à
nouvel ordre de toutes sélections
olivier rey on peut parler de clémence
relative de la fédération française de
football oui mais c'est tout de même une
affaire qui a secoué surtout terni
l'image du football français et ce au
plus mauvais moment après avoir tenu des
propos très durs sur antenne 2 à
l'encontre du sélectionneur henri michel
eric cantona est revenu en arrière il a
mis comme on dit le pied sur le ballon
en le suspendant de toute sélection
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
la fédération française a voulu montrer
qu'elle ne se laisserait pas débordé
mais elle n'a pas envenimer la situation
il faut savoir que la saison à venir
avec les matches qualificatifs pour la
prochaine coupe du monde s'annonce
décisive
or à 22 ans cantona est l'un des plus
sûrs espoirs peut-être le successeur de
platini ils devront que difficilement à
mettre hors jeu
le football français par l'intermédiaire
de la fédération a voulu adresser un
avertissement sans frais à tous les
autres joueurs
taisez-vous maintenant est joué c'est un
avertissement mais les joueurs vont
réfléchir avant de parler maintenant je
pense qu'ils vont réfléchir maintenant
si cantona et michel lors de leur
entrevue signé un armistice
on reverra très certainement eric
cantona sous le maillot de l'équipe de
france le 28 septembre prochain contre
la norvège au parc des princes pour le
premier match qualificatif pour la coupe
du monde qui est décisif parce que pour
l'instant c'est quand même un petit coup
dur pour
football français non c'est une c'est un
coup dur surtout la veille de jouer le
premier match amical de la saison contre
la tchécoslovaquie demain au parc des
pins ils ont tendu la perche on va ce
site radar décembre petit écran la
composition de l'équipe de france de
football avec de nouveaux olivier oui de
nouveau tout d'abord bien franck sauzée
espoirs qui jouait d'ailleurs avec
cantona dans l'équipe de france espoirs
qui est qualifié pour la finale de ce
championnat d'europe
et puis pardo le toulonnais qui a été
appelé en toute dernière minute pour
remplacer jean marc ferreri le bordelais
sinon une équipe qui est bien sûr
l'écran a belle allure maintenant on
verra demain de jouer rennes il est
seulement remplaçant c'est une surprise
non non c'est une demi surprise car
daniel xuereb l'attaquant du paris saint
germain souffrait d'une petite
contracture et donc il rentrera
certainement en cours de match ça
m'avait échappé d aller merci bonsoir le
sport toujours avec francis maroteaux
nous irons en belgique pour s'élever une
nouvelle performance de jeannie longo
mais avant cela voici l'image des jeux
olympiques en marche c'est est à olympie
tout naturellement la flamme de l'espoir
qui reprend force et vigueur alain py en
grèce berceau des jeux olympiques à 26
jours de l'ouverture des jeux olympiques
de séoul la flamme va donc parcourir 380
km en grèce puis ce sera le transfert
par avion dans l'île de chez vous dans
le sud de la corée
au total un parcours à travers 60 de
ville pendant 22 jours pour arriver le
10 septembre à 12h30 à celle au bras du
vin 1940 deuxième porteurs de torche et
pour séoul
voici l'une des favorites jeannie longo
actuellement à gand en belgique engagés
dans le championnat du monde sur piste
jeannie longo qui a affronté il ya
quelques minutes à peine en demi finale
de la poursuite féminine
l'américaine melinda mayfield cure qui
est bien longue ou s'est qualifié pour
la finale de ce soir où elle affrontera
la suissesse barbara jones
et finale ce soir cinéma l'un des
événements de la rentrée se déroule
demain avec la sortie de quelques jours
avec moi qui est le tout dernier film de
claude sautet
c'est un événement je le disais car
claude sautet n'avait pas tourné depuis
garçons c'était en 1983
quelques jours avec moi c'est avant tout
une grande histoire d'amour dont les
vedettes sont sandrine bonnaire et
daniel auteuil
michel pascal d'autres spécialistes il a
surpris à quelques heures de la première
après cinq ans de silence et un nouveau
claude sautet qui revient au cinéma
rajeuni tonique mordant parfois cruel
pour nous raconter le jeu un peu pervers
d'un fils de famille qui va s'amuser
avec une petite bonne de limoges jusqu'à
ce que le jeu tourne au drame
si vous voulez dîner avec moi vous aimez
le champagne ce à quoi ça rime cette
histoire comprenez pourquoi
mais comme sahin comme ça pour venir
faire une passe et sûrement une agence
en ville spécialisée dans ce genre de
trucs
je voulais seulement dîner avec vous
sautez m'a beaucoup aidé à entrer dans
ce personnage j'ai fait plus rejet au
départ mais il a une façon très très sûr
et très à lui de 2 vous prendrez de vous
faire entrer dans le personnage avec une
certaine rigueur si vous vous en plus
daniel auteuil joue martial le
propriétaire d'une chaîne de
supermarchés qui va perturber le
microcosme provincial et francine la
bonne c'est sandrine bonnaire seller
comment vous appelle et son frein les
jeux les familles non le cinglé ali et
ses proches de moi enfin dans la partie
comédie
je suis quelqu'un qui rit beaucoup dans
la vie comme elle j'ai un peu la même
manière de me déplacer sauf que dans ce
film je me tiens plus droite
ça c'était la demande de sauter et sinon
vous voyez l'état ses proches de moi je
crois au tour du couple vedette claude
sautet à lille une savoureuse galerie de
personnages hauts en couleur parmi
lesquels jean pierre marielle et
dominique lavanant qui trouve de la deux
de leurs meilleurs rôles et lit et
qu'elle joue chez nous mercredi c'est
violent comme comme comme sujet même si
ça passe par la commune dit par par le
drame
tout ce qui est comique pour moi est
assez triste
au fond et la fin est optimiste oui très
invalidante seca première centrale
d'anvers de père en fils est mort
un peu oui mais voilà dès demain
après-midi sur les grands écrans dans
quelques instants la météo de laurent
cabrol c'est tout sam ce soir soleil au
sud nuages au nord
assurez-vous il ya quand même quelques
nuances laurent nous dira tout cela avec
carte à l'appui le dernier journal sera
présentée par aubry et de l'air vers
23h15 demain n'oubliez pas vous rendez
vous habituel
6h45 c'est lé matin animé en ce moment
par sophie davant 13h le journal de la
mi-journée avec hervé claude je vous
retrouve demain à 20 heures
merci de votre fidélité et bonne soirée
sur antenne 2 bien sûr bonsoir
à